[Music]
the main stories but witches see true
what they say elves are the original
sorceress of the continent but humans
and monsters arrived else tops you miss
have to cut chaos into magic you must
look to them
chaos is the most dangerous thing in
this world
without control chaos will kill you
so that's all like this to you monsters
managed it's all it needs to me
something out there weights fee
this child will be extraordinary
Jennifer imagine the most powerful woman
in the world
do you have what it takes
you can't outrun destiny just because
you're terrified of it it's coming
I can't do this without you
no matter what you choose
the kana bloody
30-plus years of service combat medals
citations only man to shoot down three
enemy planes in last 40 years yet you
can't get a promotion won't retire
despite your best efforts he refused to
die
[Music]
you should be at least a two-star
admiral by now yet here you are captain
what is that it's one of life's
mysteries sir
[Music]
the end is inevitable maverick you kind
of set it for extinction
maybe so sir but not today
something that happens to you when you
leave this town far the way the easier
it all gets the me and I've left I
remember all of it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to the losers we made an oath I swear if
it isn't dead if it ever comes back
we'll come back to we didn't stop we
can't let it happen again
[Music]
[Music]
for 27 years
I dreamt of you
[Music]
I'll miss you
we need to finish
good
it consumes us from the inside until we
don't have a choice
you live
[Music]
Quinny tops 8 we're still 18 years why
were they here they responded to a
robbery people gonna rob 660 pounds of
coke
you drive a BMW tweedle to the job did
you bring just one other guy with you
did you only take 50 keys to see the
dumb lot or set up
to shoot us automatic weapons seconds
attila together
and refused
to allow these families to be
traumatized with trials and appeals and
parole hearing
I'm asking you to protect them from that
I understand everything about these guys
has been company so far close the island
for Island been had the 21 bridges and
shut them down three rivers closing yeah
version it is what he's to unfound
none of this makes sense because this
whole thing is filthy
what's going on here some we're trying
to figure out
whose cops are bears a city that
actively dislikes them
the city they still protect with their
lives I just need the truck you go down
this road you're on your own
but he does not bear the sword in vain
cops
fingers blood over your heads
I will find you
[Music]
gentlemen there is a war raging right
now with the Magisterium between those
trying to keep us in ignorance and those
willing to fight for truth and freedom
who will stand with me
this kind of heresy is highest priority
to the Magisterium I need to know where
he's going and what he intends to
achieve can't snake loose it's no place
for a child
the Masters asked if I can find a place
for you
and I want you as my assistant you're an
explorer too just like my uncle I can
teach you to wield power you must let me
watch you we believe there is an
organization that is stealing children
and taking north
sometimes children can Jess I promise to
do everything I could to protect you
from harm
it's in a lutely orbit it is illegal
unless approved by the Magisterium tells
you the truth
she has to make a journey one which I'm
afraid includes a great betrayal
it's trying to blow me or something
I suspect it's trying to warn you or
whatever
he scores the fight
I can fly your question shouldn't be
asking you that we're not Magisterium a
Muslim I would ask where I could obtain
services and armored bear Eric Benson
people need our help Yorick let's go
give
it's time I know when you look at every
little detail in the dark crystal those
things are the apex of somebody's art
there's a few people that know how we
did it the first time and we're so old
we don't remember everything is and
sculpted and painted just an amazing
amount of craftsmanship that you see
across the whole image the first thing
you're trying to do is live up to what
the film produced the next stage is then
to push it a lot further I think give
Hanson what a big delight in puppetry
it's an art form in itself and that's
what you're watching I feel like the
week is really the right person to be
standing in my father's shoes what's the
show
[Music]
[Music]
your destiny calls to you
[Music]
this is major Roy McBride I'm attempting
to reach dr. Clifford McBride
this is dr. McBride son
dad I'd like to see you
[Music]
I've recall how we used to watch
black/white movies together musicals
were your favorite I remember you
tutoring me in math instilled in me a
strong work ethic you should know I've
chosen a career that you would approve
of I've dedicated my life to the
exploration of space and I thank you for
that
[Music]
what is happening out there is a crisis
of unknown magnitude
[Music]
we believe your father may be involved
my father's dead what exactly are you
requiring for me
exploration is know is a noble venture
we have to hold out the possibility that
your father may be hiding from us
we have a job to do are you ready I'm
ready
[Music]
[Music]